ça vous rappelle un certain nombre de
choses importantes qui sont passées dans
votre vie et vous êtes restés en contact
étroit
nous avons été déportés ensemble
je voudrais madame veille vous poser une
question qui concerne non pas
spécialement la Chine mais disons
l'équilibre des sociétés industrialisées
et des de ce qu'on pourrait appeler les
sociétés en voie de développement et
même tout tout monstrueusement grande
que la Chine c'est aussi une société qui
est en cours de perfectionnement il s'y
pose notamment le problème de
l'équilibre alimentaire de la fin quel
est votre position
d'abord je crois que la Chine et c'est
ce qu'il faut mettre peut-être en
premier à l'actif de ce pays a résolu le
problème de la fin quand on sait ce qui
était les famines en Chine avant la
Révolution cette cette réussite
exemplaire sur ce plan-là
et puisque Marceline évoque les Indes
pronom qui n'est pas sorti c'est ça
il m'a dit ça vous gêne que je tutoie
marseillais non ça ne me gêne pas du
tout si vous vous tutoyez naturellement
faites-le alors c'était ça n'est-ce pas
l'époque le problème des Indes je crois
que nous avons tous un peu un peu
mauvaise conscience quand nous voyons
que nous sommes dans une société
d'abondance non seulement d'abondance
mais souvent de gaspillage de savoir
qu'il y a encore tant de gens qui
meurent de faim et ça pose un problème
ne leur problème les relations entre les
pays en voie de développement et je n'y
mets plus la Chine puisque elle a
résolution ces problèmes-là et ceux de
du monde des nations je dirais pas le
monde occidental mais les nations
industrialisées qui elles font procède
un gaspillage sur le plan nutritionnel
de façon très très importante on peut
dire que nous sommes nous mourrons
d'excès de nourriture quand d'autres
meurent de faim il y a là quelque chose
de très choquant comment doivent
s'équilibrer les choses pour vous
est-ce qu'il faut que nous apprenions
nous société policiers industrialisées
et qui vivons dans le bien-être
alimentaire apprendre à se nourrir plus
sainement et donc peut-être à moins
gaspiller sûrement seulement c'est un
intérêt en soi et bien sûr qu'il faut
mais il faut aussi rechercher comment
nous pouvons aider les pays en voie de
développement à avoir ce qui leur faut
une suffira pas qu'on consomme moins
pour que les autres et pour autant et
c'est aussi là le problème alors ça
c'est un problème politique le premier
est un problème de politique sanitaire
dans notre pays mais il y a aussi un
problème dans le pays où vous exercez
une responsabilité gouvernementale le
problème de politique sanitaire je crois
qu'il y a un
des projets en matière de prévention de
d'essayer par toutes les moyens les
masses médias d'apprendre un Français à
avoir une meilleure hygiène alimentaire
qu'il s'agisse de ce qu'il mange ou ce
qu'ils boivent mais je crois qu'au-delà
de ça il y a le problème politique j'ai
eu l'occasion au mois de décembre
dernier d'aller à la FAO pour exposer
que c'est l'organisation mondiale de la
de la fin de l'alimentation qui
justement se penche sur les problèmes
d'une meilleure répartition des produits
alimentaires dans le monde je sais que
vous fuyez beaucoup la formulation
politique mais je crois que quand même
il nous en parlera un peu plus en détail
tout à l'heure à partir d'un autre
problème vous met une action d'où la
politique n'est absolument pas exclue
quoi que vous en veuillez est-ce que
vous vous sentez une progressiste ou ce
qu'on pourrait appeler de façon un peu
schématique une femme conservateur
non je me sens pas conservateur je me
sens progressiste n'est peut-être pas le
mot parce que c'est un sens politique
engagé qui n'est pas le mien mais je me
sens quelqu'un de progrès j'espère être
ressenti comme ça lorsque vous voyez
Marceline leur Ridan et avant de passer
à la séquence suivante ça vous rappelle
un certain nombre de choses importantes
qui sont passées dans votre vie et vous
êtes restés en contact étroit
nous avons été déportés ensemble je
pense que c'est une chose suffisamment
dur et après tout qui est absolument pas
utile d'évoquer j'aurais bien aimé
entendre ce tutoiement quand même alors
je peux lui demander si tu vas bien
on y arrive tout de même madame je vous
invite à passer si vous le voulez bien à
la place réservée au traitement de
[Musique]